okay it's time for really obvious stuff
that in the Trump era we actually have
to say out loud because a lot of people
don't seem to understand it or they fall
in for talking points and have been
confused about what the reality is the
foreign help that Trump said last week
in an interview with George
Stephanopoulos he would welcome from
other countries is illegal okay last
week to remind you Donald Trump was
interviewed on ABC News by George
Stephanopoulos and he was asked what
would you do President Trump if in 2020
once again Russia or China or whoever
comes to you with dirt on your eventual
Democratic opponent and Donald Trump
said that he would accept the
information because of course nothing
says I didn't collude in 2016 like
saying I'd be willing to collude in 2020
let me remind you of what Donald Trump
said just so we all are familiar with
the clip I'm referring to today you're
going to the FBI when he got that okay
let's put yourself in a position you're
a congressman somebody comes up and says
hey I have information on your opponent
do you call the FBI I think I mean from
day one you do I've seen a lot of things
over in my life I don't think in my
whole life I've ever called the FBI in
my whole life I don't you don't call the
FBI you throw somebody out of your
office you do whatever Gore got a stolen
briefing book he called the FBI well
that's different as stolen briefing but
this is under stuff this is somebody
that said we have information on your
opponent oh let me call the FBI give me
a break life doesn't work order Ector
says that's what should happen the FBI
director is wrong your campaign this
time around if foreigners if Russia if
China if someone else offers you
information on opponents should they
accept it or should they call the FBI I
think maybe you do both I think you
might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if somebody
called from a country Norway we have
information on your opponent oh I think
I'd want to hear you want that kind of
interference in our elections it's not
an interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I'd go maybe to the FBI
if I thought there was something wrong
but when somebody comes up with a poor
research right they come up with a poor
research
oh let's call the FBI the FBI doesn't
have enough agents to take care of it
but you go and talk honestly to God
they all do it they always have and
that's the way it is
it's called Oppo research okay so all of
that foreign Oppo research that Trump is
referring to is illegal to accept as an
American presidential candidate there's
a very good piece in the LA Times which
outlines a variety of different views on
this and what's important to understand
is that it is quote unlawful for a
foreign national directly or indirectly
keywords directly or indirectly to make
a contribution or donation of money or
other thing of value or other thing of
value important or to make an express or
implied promise to make a contribution
or donation in connection with a federal
state or local election it is also
illegal for a campaign to quote solicit
accept or receive anything of value from
a foreigner so it's two-sided it's
illegal for the foreigners to do it
whether you can actually hold them
accountable if they're not in the United
States is a question mark it seems to be
now and it's equally illegal for the
recipient in the United States to do the
receiving Trump said he would accept it
and receive it it is therefore something
that would be against the law
Ellen Weintraub chairs the FEC she put
out a statement saying quote let me make
something 100% clear to the American
public and anyone running for public
office it is illegal for any person to
solicit accept or receive anything of
value from a foreign national in
connection with a US election now let's
be thorough there are some lawyers who
are disputing that dirt on opponents is
a specifically quantifiable thing of
value meaning it might not be illegal in
this way the idea is dirt on an opponent
which helps you win is worth what if you
can't put a specific dollar value on it
it's not quantifiably a thing of value
and therefore it might sort of skirt
around the illegality that Ellen
Weintraub says exists so you might say
well if I get dirt from my opponent and
it helps me win and my salary is a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars a year was the dirt worth a
hundred and
5,000 well it's not quite so cut-and-dry
but what this ignores is that it's worth
something and this is why lots of legal
experts say even if we can't say exactly
what the value is of that dirt on
opponents it has value and in addition
to that the foreign country has
presumably spent some amount of money
and resources in gathering that dirt on
your opponents which gives it more
specific value if it costs a foreign
national fifty thousand dollars to
gather this dirt on your opponent then
we can much more easily say well it's
worth fifty thousand dollars because
that's what it cost the foreign national
that's what it cost the foreign national
to obtain that information so I think it
is one of the weakest defenses I've
heard that it's not really illegal
because we can't specifically quantify
the value of the dirt it has value it
costs money
to obtain the dirt and by the way Donald
Trump also said in that interview with
George Stephanopoulos that everyone is
doing this that's not true I mean sure
it's probably true that someone is doing
it but unless Donald Trump can start
citing specific examples of where
American candidates and elected
officials accepted things of value in
this way from foreign powers it's on him
to tell us that everybody is doing it
and to prove that everybody is doing it
and think how far we've come
from the beginning to this interview
with George Stephanopoulos there was
nothing with any foreign country there
was something but no Trump insiders had
a clue there was something and some
Trump insiders had a clue but it wasn't
illegal - oh yeah we do it all again in
2020 emboldened like the sort of little
kids that they effectively are don't let
them get away with this don't let them
get away with this again in 2020 we can
vote them out yes the playing field is
not level it's stacked against us as I
said in the first segment in today's
show but if enough people vote we can
override that and we can actually get
him out and that's what we need to be
doing because he's saying it on national
television he would do it all again let
me know what you think I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video